oh my gosh this is real this is
happening you don't have to tune into a
twin only zoom call to see that there
are a lot of familiar faces out there on
social media just what is it about twins
that makes them so popular some of the
biggest tick tocking twins have some
thought on that
but while some sets base their fame off
their family others have a more low-key
twin you might not even know exists
we don't look as much alike as we used
to but yeah we're identical thanks to
the suite life of zack & cody dylan and
Cole Sprouse might be some of the most
famous twins around on the show these
identical twins had the opportunity to
work with superstar Selena Gomez and
Dylan took part in her first kiss on set
the problem selena called it one of the
worst days of her life since she had a
huge crush on Cole years later Cole
joked that unlike his brother nobody has
ever said that about kissing him Cole
stuck with acting and appeared on
Riverdale as Jughead Jones while Dylan
took a break to open all wise meatery in
New York although these brothers would
love to work together again they'd want
to get a gig based on their own talents
and not just because they're twins there
was a time when identical twins lisa and
lena manler we're the number one account
on tik-tok before they deleted the app
they started out lip-synching on
musically and quickly became popular but
when it switched to tick tock the twins
decided they wanted to do something now
they also cited concerns about
tick-tocks privacy policy and some
security issues but if you are a fan of
their videos don't worry because they've
recently rejoined although they're going
back to basics they've also started
their own clothing brand j1 mo7 one they
may not have a special twin language but
german is their native language and they
started learning english after getting
popular online Veronica and Vanessa are
known as the Meryl twins and don't let
their dad Paul fool you he isn't really
the third Meryl twin these two are
identical but while vanessa has dimples
on both cheeks
Veronica only has one on her left side
while they don't have their own written
language they claim to converse using
sign language sometimes they got their
start making YouTube videos with the
help of their parents but they're hoping
to finish their college degrees when
they can find tae
their schedules Veronica hopes to be a
screenwriter while vanessa was studying
production before their hiatus from
school they were glad to stop by the
zoom based twin party hosted by Ethan
and grayson dolan but they also want
their fans to know that they're not
dating the dillon twins and they're not
sure why everyone seems to think they
are scarlet johansson portrays natasha
romanoff in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but behind the scenes the star
has a twin brother not many people know
about Hunter is three minutes older than
his sister and he tends to tower over
her but he's happy to let Scarlett have
the spotlight and focuses on the
nonprofit organization he founded called
solar responders they help provide first
responders with backup systems that run
on renewable energy and scarlet couldn't
be more proud she's called him the most
altruistic person she knows and says he
reminds her to be a better person
although they may not have a secret twin
language their parents did they
frequently spoke Dutch around Scarlett
and Hunter knowing that their Twins
wouldn't be able to figure out what they
were saying there are tons of tick tock
stars who got their start on musically
but Ethan and Grayson have been big
since back in the days of vine even
though they joke about not looking alike
they're identical twins and now they
don't have a triplet named Nolan these
two quickly gains popularity on YouTube
but took a sabbatical after the loss of
their father Shaun Dolan in 2019 in
addition to getting back to work
creating content they're also putting
out a weekly podcast called deeper with
the Dolan twins every Tuesday they
discussed various issues that go way
beyond the light-hearted fun they share
with their fans on their YouTube channel
they also took time out of their busy
schedules to host a huge zoom party with
tons of other famous siblings rami malek
is a one-of-a-kind star in terms of
talent but in terms of his appearance he
does have an identical twin brother
named Sammy just how much do these two
look alike
well according to Rami he once pretended
to be Sammy in college so he could
deliver a monologue for his class
apparently the teacher was suspicious
but she likes the performance so much
she asked him to repeat it for another
one of her classes
even though Sammy needed some help from
his brother it doesn't mean he's not a
good student and
axé he now works as a teacher and has
his own class full of troublesome
students it can be amazing to see how
identical twins look just like each
other and then there's niki and gabi
DiMartino yes as hard as it is to
believe they're technically identical
twins even though they look totally
different
they started out by making a YouTube
channel where they share their covers of
songs and music videos but despite their
best lip syncing all their fans wanted
to know was how they did their makeup it
turns out the audience loved their
distinct styles and wanted to know how
to recreate their looks so the twins
started a new Beauty focused channel
Gabby's ventured into the music industry
and debut album beautiful mess is set to
be released in fall of 2020 while Niki
runs her own YouTube channel in addition
to the ones she shares with her sis fake
twin alert you have to admit sisters
charlie and dixie dee Emilio do look a
lot alike so it's not too surprising
that a lot of fans think they're twins
they're so strikingly similar that the
Dolan twins invited them to their zoom
party that was supposed to be twins only
but the truth is they're just standard
siblings and Dixie is older than her
sister charlie Dixie might have been
born first but she has a ways to go
before she catches up with her little
sister in terms of tick tock followers
now let's get back to the actual twins
on our list Brooklyn and Bailey McKnight
are identical twins and in this case
brick Lee is a whole two minutes older
they got their start on YouTube and soon
they decide to connect with other twins
and start a new channel called squared
according to the National Center for
Health Statistics there are more twins
today than ever before so Brooklyn and
Bailey have plenty of twin centric
contents for their channel outside of
their online success these two are
attending Baylor University and plans to
major in entrepreneurship even though
the mesquita twins are identical there
are some pretty big differences between
them according to Ashley olivia is more
organized of the two well Ashley is more
of a social butterfly than her sister
for these twins believe their
differences have helped them become
successful because they each bring
different strengths to their business
but don't get us wrong they have a ton
in common too these two had most of the
same classes in high school and how
others study for their exams they
started out with a YouTube vlog but now
they're getting popular on tik-tok as
well these two know that as long as they
stick together they can handle anything
when it comes to Fame sometimes two
really is better than one and alex
stokes thinks he knows why twins are so
popular he and his twin brother Alan
create videos on YouTube and style
themselves similarily to highlight their
identical appearance but behind the
scenes alex admits they often dress more
differently although they won't do
drastic aesthetic changes without
discussing it first
according to Alex it's not just that
fans like seeing twins so they enjoy
seeing the chemistry between them when
they interact he pointed out that
channels showcasing romantic couples
tend to perform well since the people
are close to one another and this is
also the case with twins even though
they have a lot in common
Alex and Alan want to showcase the fact
that there are individuals which is why
they each have their own Instagram
account still alex has admitted that the
very idea of being separated from his
twin makes him feel afraid if you're a
fan of their funny videos you can also
find the Stokes twins on tick tock
unlike many other famous twins Sarah and
Tegan ripka didn't get their start
online instead they wowed the audience
when they appeared on Australia's Got
Talent
even though they didn't win they got
their names out there and now you can
find their footage on YouTube and tick
tock in addition to being twins Sam and
Tegan are talented acrobats and dancers
who aren't afraid to show what they can
do they've even written a full book
about their careers called twinning net
dance acro YouTube and living life to
the fullest before they became the
youngest members of the tic-tock
creators collective known as the hype
house Jack and James frights were just
normal high school students at school
they ended up in the top eight in the
nation for pole vault and shut foot and
James the proud member of the track and
field team since they're members of hype
house it's no surprise that they love
posting videos on tic toc and the
sillier the better even though they have
lots of followers their dad will might
be their biggest fan
he's always posting supportive content
on his Instagram accounts and it's clear
as twins have family at home and in the
hype house
Lucas and Markus dobre started out on
vine
posting everything from pranks to dances
to vlogs and everything in between these
identical siblings for once known as the
twin BOTS and you might have noticed
that they're not shy about showing off
their acrobatic skills they probably
picked it up from their mom who is
irelia dobre a world champion gymnast
Lucas and Marcus were original members
of Team ten but now their focus is on
making YouTube videos with their other
non twin siblings Cyrus and Darius their
vests known as twin melody but these two
identical twins are Etana and Paula at
Siberia after winning a singing
competition these two started their own
YouTube channel to showcase their
singing and songwriting skills they also
have a tik-tok channel with over 13
million followers so far in addition to
checking out their online content you
can also shop their music and merch on
their store Instagram paid oh I'm going
to Nikki and Gabi's let's go to Nikki
and Gabi's Nikki and Gabi's it was never
Gabi and Nikki do you think twins will
continue to be in or is this trend
destined to end let us know what you
think in the comments click subscribe
for more great videos from us here at
the things thanks for watching
you